- Good afternoon.
Here we are.
It's been an incredible few days,
and there's still lots more to come.
This weekend we've
remembered, we've talked,
we've debated, we've laughed.
Some of us have cried.
This final programmatic
salute to the first
women in Yale College includes
two different kinds of segments.
One segment includes short videos
created by Kyle Gibson Class of 1978
from the wonderful oral histories
taken by some of you,
or given by some of you,
during the course of the last few years.
The oral history includes
many more deeply compelling interviews,
but these brief excerpts capture
a fraction of your brilliant voices
and touch on some themes
common to that first wild year,
especially the challenges, the hurdles,
and the surprises that
came with being a part
of that tumultuous, historic time.
The rest of the program
is music from our era,
some of it performed either
by groups or members of groups
that were founded during our era,
some of it by more current groups
selected because they sing
music that is relevant.
We felt that music from our era would be
good background for our memories,
and we also felt that having the music
sung by today's undergraduates,
most of them women,
would be inspiring since they are
the triumphant outcome of what we began.
Along the way, I, Connie Royster,
and Shelley Fisher
Fishkin, and Julia Preston
will provide some brief narration
to introduce, guide, and explain.
So, to begin, our first group
will be the Slavic chorus.
- [Audience Member] Yay.
(Connie laughing)
(audience applauding)
- Founded in 1969, the first year
of undergraduate co-education at Yale.
And I know there are members
of the Slavic chorus here in the audience.
Would you please stand up
and wave so we can see you.
(audience cheering and applauding)
The Slavs have been wildly praised,
not only for their sound
but for their authenticity.
In 2019 they celebrated
their 50th anniversity
with a reunion concert that drew alumni
from across the globe.
Without further adieu, I
give you today's Slavs,
a chorus that has always been dedicated
to maintaining musical excellence
and seeking to empower women through song.
They will be singing one
of their earliest songs
from our era, "Erghen
Deda," a song from Bulgaria.
(audience applauding)
(chorus singing in a foreign language)
(chorus members clapping in time)
(audience cheering and applauding)
- What a wonderful performance.
Thank you, Slavs.
The New Blue was also founded in 1969,
another of the very first of
Yale women's singing groups.
In that year, Ben O'Keefe, Bill Harwood,
and Jim Weber of the Yale Glee Club
held the first auditions for a brand new,
all women's a cappella singing group.
The 11 women who auditioned
were accepted into the group.
With a pitch and a
business manager assigned
and a single arrangement from Feno,
the women were on their own.
These dynamic women soon
dubbed themselves The New Blue,
a name representing a new face of Yale,
recasting the mold of Yale's Old Blue.
At first, not surprising to us,
it was difficult for The New
Blue to be taken seriously.
When a member of a male
a cappella group quipped,
"The New Who?", The New Blue decided
to entitle their first
album "Since You Asked."
(audience laughing)
Today, The New Blue is a
core part of the Yale scene.
They have delighted audiences worldwide
and have sung for former Presidents
George Bush and Barack Obama.
And I think there's some members
of The New Blue in the audience.
Would you please stand and wave.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Woo.
I now give you the inimitable New Blue
celebrating what I hope is our
present frame of mind, "Feeling Good".
(audience applauding)
♪ Birds fly high ♪
♪ Birds flyin' high ♪
(women singing backup harmony)
♪ You know how I feel ♪
♪ Sun in the sky ♪
♪ Breeze driftin' on by ♪
♪ You know how I feel ♪
♪ It's a new dawn ♪
♪ It's a new day ♪
♪ It's a new life for me ♪
♪ And I'm feelin' good ♪
♪ Oh oh oh oh feelin' good ♪
♪ Fish in the sea ♪
♪ You know how I feel ♪
♪ River runnin' free ♪
♪ Blossom on a tree ♪
♪ You know how I feel ♪
♪ It's a new dawn ♪
♪ It's a new day ♪
♪ It's a new life for me ♪
♪ And I'm feelin' good ♪
♪ Dragonfly out in the sun ♪
♪ You know what I mean, don't you know ♪
♪ Butterflies all havin' fun ♪
♪ You know what I mean ♪
♪ Sleepin' peace when day is done ♪
♪ That's what I mean ♪
♪ And this old world is a new world ♪
♪ And a bolder world for me ♪
♪ Oh, for me ♪
(women singing harmony)
♪ Stars when you shine ♪
♪ You know how I feel ♪
♪ Scent of the pine ♪
♪ Oh, freedom is mine ♪
♪ And I know how I feel ♪
♪ It's a new dawn ♪
♪ It's a new day ♪
♪ It's a new life ♪
♪ It's a new dawn ♪
♪ It's a new day ♪
♪ It's a new life ♪
♪ It's a new dawn ♪
♪ It's a new day ♪
♪ It's a new life ♪
♪ It's a new life for me ♪
♪ And I'm feelin' good ♪
(women snapping in time)
♪ I'm feelin' good ♪
♪ And I feel so good ♪
♪ And I'm feeling good ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Thank you.
The New Blue.
Pretty good.
(audience laughing)
Before the first part of the video clips,
we thought we would set the
mood with "The Way We Were,"
a tune from the 1973 romantic drama
starring Barbara Streisand
and Robert Redford.
To sing it for us, we have Sara Speller.
Sara graduated from Yale last May
and is about to leave for England
to take up a fellowship to pursue
an Mphil in Musicology at Oxford.
She will be accompanied today
by Mahima Humara from the Class of 2020,
an accomplished pianist,
who has received awards
at the Duquesne Young
Artist National Competition
and the Pennsylvania Music Teachers
National Association Competition.
She's a member of Yale's
Undergraduate Piano Collective.
The song will be followed by the montage
from a few of the 100 or so
voices we've captured thus far
about those first days and
weeks and months at Yale,
especially the challenges that came
with breaking a barrier
more than 250 years old
at an entrenched patriarchal institution.
(audience laughing)
And now, Sara and Mahima.
(audience applauding)
(gentle piano music)
(Sara humming)
♪ Memories ♪
♪ Light the corners of my mind ♪
♪ Misty water-colored memories ♪
♪ Of the way we were ♪
♪ Scattered pictures ♪
♪ Of the smiles we left behind ♪
♪ Smiles we gave to one another ♪
♪ For the way we were ♪
♪ Could it be that it
was all so simple then ♪
♪ Or has time rewritten every line ♪
♪ If we had the chance
to do it all again ♪
♪ Tell me, would we ♪
♪ Could we ♪
♪ Memories ♪
♪ May be beautiful and yet ♪
♪ What's too painful to remember ♪
♪ We simply choose to forget ♪
♪ So it's the laughter ♪
♪ We will remember ♪
♪ Whenever we remember ♪
♪ The way we were ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
(audience chattering)
- It appealed to my sense of history,
my sense of wanting to achieve and strive.
And I loved the idea of being able to be
in the first class of something
to make something work.
- Women were sort of
devalued in my family,
significantly devalued.
I mean, I remember when my parents
would have the extended family over,
and I wanted to be in the den
with the men talking
about law and politics.
My mother would say, "No, no,
"you need to come in the kitchen with us
"and talk about what we talk about."
Which was not law and politics.
And that's just one example.
There was so much of that.
And so, I just thought, well, I guess
the way to be worthwhile in life
is to be more like a man, to
have masculine characteristics.
And Yale would be a great
place to sort of find that.
(audience laughing)
- I grew up in New Haven.
I was born in New Haven, just
two blocks behind the gym,
Payne Whitney Gym.
My Aunt Edna Carnegie said to me
that my grandfather would be turning over
in his grave knowing
that his granddaughter
had been admitted to Yale.
- And when I arrived at the campus,
all the stores had welcome students signs,
and one said, "Welcome Yalettes."
(audience laughing)
Which just made me cringe.
- My parents took me in the station wagon,
and there were a lot of reporters around
asking me questions.
And I do remember being
absolutely clueless
as to what to say to these people.
- There was so much media
coverage it was embarrassing.
I remember being, I
think, on the front page
with a couple of other local girls.
I did not want that, and they had also
taken a lot of our comments
on phone interviews
completely out of context, made us sound
like the most entitled
(laughing), privileged,
upper class terrible people.
- If I could go back and talk
to the young Betsy going to Yale,
I would say, "You are brave.
"You are a pioneer.
"You are doing something really amazing."
- And it was the first time I
really felt I could be myself.
Not only that, but the place
was full of smart people.
I was no longer the odd person out.
It was the first time in
my life I felt normal.
- I think I was in heaven (laughing).
I mean, it was, you
know, it was very funny.
I, many years later, a
woman who was my roommate
junior year who had also
transferred from Smith with me,
we had gone to a Yale reunion,
maybe it was our 20th
reunion or something.
And she told she had just
come back from a panel
of women who had graduated in the '80s,
who were all complaining
that we didn't have this,
and we didn't have that.
And I remember Susan
looked at me, and she said,
"It never occurred to us to complain.
"We were so damn grateful
to just be there."
- So, I think in my class
there were 100 women,
and there were, as Kingman
Brewster proudly told us
on the first day a thousand
male leaders, right?
So, the ratio was extreme.
- And they were welcoming us.
And the first thing that of
course the staff says is,
"The mission of Yale College is
"to shape a thousand male leaders
"(chuckling) in each class."
and from the back of the common room,
there was a female voice
that piped up saying,
"What about us?"
And I always remember
the laughter after that
because no mention was made about
this is a historic moment,
the first class of women.
They basically pretended
that we weren't there.
- I don't think it really occurred to me
what it was gonna feel
like in the classroom
where there were both male
professors and male students
who really wished we weren't there.
- There were 17 men in
the major and myself.
And when I arrived, I had
on a very colorful outfit,
and the professor, who was British,
said, "You must be in the wrong place."
(audience laughing)
I said, "Is this MB&B 302?"
Or whatever.
And he said, "Yes."
I said, "Well, then I'm in the major."
And he was stunned, and
he looked on the list.
He asked my name, and
there I was on the list.
And he said, "Well, Miss Gluckin will add
"lovely colors and nice
sense to the class."
(audience laughing)
I was incensed.
I was furious.
So, I studied super hard,
and on the first quiz,
I did better than anyone else on the quiz.
They were handing, the
results were handed out,
and he recanted.
- I felt very competitive, like I could,
not blend in but that I could fit in.
And I think there's a
big difference between,
because I didn't feel like
I had to give up anything.
I felt that, and I also
felt welcomed by the
white male students
who were in my classes.
So, I was going in as a junior.
I was going into advanced
psychology courses so I,
and the only thing that
was sometimes awkward
is if sometimes they looked for me
to the female point of view
or to the black point of view.
And I can't speak for all women.
I can't speak for all black people.
But at least I felt like I was
not being, not getting pushback.
- I was my freshmen year, and it was
in direct studies in my English class,
where I had been getting A's on my papers
that you write a paper every week.
And then, all of a sudden
I got a C on a paper,
and the note said, "See me."
So, I had to go to the office of the guy.
I get to the office, and it turned out
that he made a pass at me,
chased me around the room,
tried to lock me in the room.
It was really appalling.
And luckily, I'm from the West
Coast in a co-ed environment.
And I looked at him and
like, "Are you serious?"
That's what, (laughing)
I wasn't frightened.
I was just like appalled
that this was happening.
So, I found a way to get out of there.
And then, you think it would be over.
I told my roommates.
I didn't report it.
And then, the next week,
I write another paper.
I got a D on the paper and a note saying,
"This is the best paper
you've written all year."
I'm thinking, this guy is an idiot.
So, the next week, I think I might've
even gotten an F on one.
And my roommates were like,
"You have to report him."
And I said, "Oh, no."
If he proceeds with this,
I don't wanna wreck anyone's career.
If he persists in wanting me
to go to his office, I won't go.
And finals day comes, and
they pass out the blue books.
And I sat in the front
row, and this teacher
got up to the podium and gave
the instructions for the exam.
And before he left for the exam,
I got up and went up to
the podium with my back
to everybody so they couldn't
tell what I was saying.
And I said, "Excuse me, sir.
"Shall I take the exam, or
are you going to fail me?"
And he looked at me, and
said, "Take the exam."
So, I took the exam, and I
got a good grade in the class.
And I think I still have
those papers (laughing).
Because it was to me, you know,
it wasn't until later that I realized
that this kind of person might be doing
this to someone who was more vulnerable,
but it was a strange time.
- This was the first year.
There was nothing there, I mean,
even for women who were huge
athletes, which I wasn't.
But for women who were, there were no,
you know, there were no
organized sports teams.
- It was a bit of a shock to me to come in
and ask where I could sign
up for the field hockey team
and have the gentleman behind the desk
look at me like I was
asking to go to Mars.
He just looked at me
blankly, like, what's that?
So, that was discouraging, but, you know,
like so many of the women
in that first class,
I think, probably we were here in part
because we were resilient creatures.
And so we decided to go ahead.
If there wasn't a field hockey team,
we would start one,
and that's what we did.
- There were so few Asian Americans,
and I didn't think that it was unusual
to have Asian Americans, having
grown up in part in Hawaii.
But to see how isolated we were.
So, I started working with a number
of other Asian Americans.
We ended up co-founding something called
the Asian American, it's now called
the Asian American Student Alliance,
which just celebrated
its 50th anniversary.
- There was still the phenomenon
of Friday afternoon
buses arriving on campus
with young women from other schools
who were coming for the weekend
with their hat boxes or
suitcases or what have you
dressed in skirts, that
I remember distinctly
while most of us were dressed in jeans.
And realizing that, you know, the guys
who were your friends during the week
now were, you know, having a
social experience with other women.
You know, that you didn't
count in that category.
- I was active in the student
government of my college,
and that was one the things I'm like
we're not spending any money bringing
women into the college, you know?
Let their college pay for the buses.
We're not paying for
buses for women any more.
And people thought that was horrible,
but, you know, it's like, why should
my money go to bus these girls in
when I don't have a date, you know?
(audience laughing)
- It was kind of hard to avoid.
You know, as soon as you decided
you didn't enjoy this one, another one
or two or three showed up.
- I set a rule for myself freshman year
that I would only got
out on four dates a week.
(audience member laughing)
And I stuck to it.
And (laughing) it was, I had a lot of fun.
- I had a song written to me that was
sung every time I entered the
dining hall at Pearson College.
The song was written by a
man named Don Tenneblatt.
He would sit at the grand piano
in the lobby of Pearson College,
and when I would come in
for dinner he would sing it.
♪ I'm from Little Rock, Arkansas ♪
♪ I'm happy that I got to know y'all ♪
♪ I'm pretty as sin ♪
♪ But I won't let you in ♪
♪ I'm hot shit, but
I'll never show y'all ♪
(audience laughing)
That's my song.
And so, that was something I
had never experienced before.
I can't say that it was a treat
for me to hear that repeatedly.
It certainly made me very self-conscious.
I also had such things as
eggs put into my mailbox.
Yes, I don't why, hard boiled eggs.
I guess 'cause I was considered
to be a hard boiled egg (laughing).
I don't know what.
(audience chuckling)
- I have an absolutely impossible time
imagining my daughter, who
went to Yale College also,
putting up with any of what
I put up with (laughing).
- I very much did feel like a pioneer.
And no one knew what would
happen when we came to Yale.
- I felt like I was a trailblazer
and wanted to make this grand experiment
of co-education that could've gone
severely off the rails but did not.
- It planted those seeds
of, of wanting to serve,
or wanting to be of use to other people.
- Essential to my even thinking
about what I wanted to do in my life.
(audience applauding)
- The video shows us some
of what we confronted.
Part of the challenges that year for women
interested in the arts was what was
going to be available for us.
The Slavs early on formed
themselves as a new group.
What about the Yale Glee Club?
Founded in 1861 and a men's organization
for well over 100 years when we arrived.
In 1969-70,
that academic year, there was
initially still a four-part men's chorus
and a new women's chorus.
They toured together at
the end of that year,
singing separately and together.
And during that successful tour,
it was decided that
the groups would merge,
and the Glee Club would go co-ed.
The transition happened over
the course of that first year,
and the 1970-71 Yale Glee Club
was the first officially
co-ed Yale Glee Club.
The Yale Glee Club of
today is world famous.
Their performances have
received rave reviews
in the national press
and the New York Times,
which has called it one
of the best collegiate
singing ensembles and one
of the most adventurous.
The Glee Club, of course,
is a mixed chorus.
But for this special occasion,
the director has set a song
for a group of nine women,
who will sing from its
earliest repertoire.
So, now, from the Beatles,
women from the Glee Club
singing Paul McCartney's "Yesterday."
(audience cheering and applauding)
(gentle piano music)
♪ Yesterday ♪
♪ All my troubles seemed so far away ♪
♪ Now it looks as though
they're here to stay ♪
♪ Oh, I believe in yesterday ♪
♪ Suddenly ♪
♪ I'm not half the man I used to be ♪
♪ There's a shadow hanging over me ♪
♪ Oh, yesterday came suddenly ♪
♪ Why she had to go ♪
♪ I don't know ♪
♪ She wouldn't say ♪
♪ I said something wrong ♪
♪ Now I long for yesterday ♪
♪ Yesterday, yesterday ♪
♪ Love was such an easy game to play ♪
♪ Now I need a place to hide away ♪
♪ Oh, I believe in yesterday ♪
♪ Why she had to go ♪
♪ I don't know ♪
♪ She wouldn't say ♪
♪ I said something wrong ♪
♪ Now I long for yesterday ♪
♪ Yesterday ♪
♪ Love was such an easy game to play ♪
♪ Now I need a place to hide away ♪
♪ Oh, I believe in yesterday ♪
♪ Mm mm mm mm mm mm mm ♪
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Yale Glee Club.
That was absolutely beautiful.
And if there are members from the first
classes of women who
were in the Glee Club,
please stand and wave to us.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Tangled Up in Blue, pronounced T.U.I.B,
was not a group that existed in our years.
But although they sing
a varied repertoire,
they have a distinct
folk '60s and '70s vibe
and are partial to the folk rock hits
of Dylan, to the jams of
Crosby, Stills, Nash, and Young,
and to the sounds of Simon and Garfunkel.
Today they will sing the lead song
of the Dylan album of the same name,
"The Times They are A-Changin'"
as they certainly were
during our time at Yale.
Welcome, T.U.I.B.
(audience applauding)
(gentle acoustic guitar music)
♪ Come gather 'round, people ♪
♪ Wherever you roam ♪
♪ And admit that the waters
around you have grown ♪
♪ And accept that soon you'll
be drenched to the bone ♪
♪ If your time to you is worth savin' ♪
♪ And you better start swimmin' ♪
♪ Or you'll sink like a stone ♪
♪ For the times they are a-changin' ♪
♪ Come writers and critics
who prophesy with your pen ♪
♪ And keep your eyes wide ♪
♪ The chance won't come again ♪
♪ And don't speak too soon ♪
♪ For the wheel's still in spin ♪
♪ And there's no tellin'
who that it's namin' ♪
♪ For the loser now will be later to win ♪
♪ For the times they are a-changin' ♪
♪ Come mothers and fathers
throughout the land ♪
♪ And don't criticize what
you can't understand ♪
♪ Your sons and your daughters
are beyond your command ♪
♪ Your old road is rapidly aging ♪
♪ So get out of the new one
if you can't lend your hand ♪
♪ For the times they are a-changin' ♪
♪ Come senators, congressman,
please heed the call ♪
♪ Don't stand in the doorway ♪
♪ Don't block up the hall ♪
♪ For he who gets hurt will
be he who has stalled ♪
♪ There's a battle
outside and it's ragin' ♪
♪ It'll soon shake your
windows and rattle your walls ♪
♪ For the times they are a-changin' ♪
♪ The line it is drawn ♪
♪ The curse it is cast ♪
♪ The slow one now will later be fast ♪
♪ As the present now will later be past ♪
♪ The order is rapidly fadin' ♪
♪ And the first one now
will later be last ♪
♪ For the times they are a-changin' ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Alright, good, alright.
Good job, thank you, alright.
Now for a change of pace.
Cami Arboles of the Class of 2020,
one of Yale's prominent
undergraduate singers
in the classical and
musical theater scene,
is going to sing a song by Otis Redding
with lyrics adapted by the
person who made the song
so famous, the incomparable
Aretha Franklin.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Cami is an actress, singer, and dancer
and an active member of the Yale Aerial
and Circus Arts Collective.
(audience laughing)
Her performance of "Respect," and perhaps
it's not necessary to explain
why we chose this song,
(audience laughing)
will be followed immediately by a
second montage of the video interviews.
This one deals with our
responses to May Day,
an episode that united Yale women and men
around a historic event
they experienced together.
(audience applauding)
- One, two, three, four.
(upbeat piano music)
♪ Oooo ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ What you want ♪
♪ Baby I got it ♪
♪ What you need, boy ♪
♪ You know I've got it ♪
♪ All I'm askin' ♪
♪ Is for a little
respect when I get home ♪
♪ Baby, when you get home ♪
♪ Mister, now ♪
♪ I ain't gonna do you wrong ♪
♪ When you're gone ♪
♪ I don't wanna ♪
♪ All I'm askin' is for a little respect ♪
♪ When you get home, baby ♪
♪ When you get home, my darling, oh ♪
♪ I'm a girl to give you ♪
♪ All my money ♪
♪ And you know what I
want from you, my honey ♪
♪ Is just a little respect
when you get home ooo ooo ♪
♪ When you get home, yeah ♪
♪ Ooo ♪
♪ Mmm, baby ♪
♪ Need some respect, yeah ♪
♪ Ooo your kiss now ♪
♪ Is sweeter than honey ♪
♪ But you know what else is ♪
♪ Boy, my money ♪
♪ And I'm askin' is for a little respect ♪
♪ When you get home, my baby, now ♪
♪ When you get home, yeah ♪
♪ R-E-S-P-E-C-T ♪
♪ Find out what it means to me ♪
♪ Take care, TCB, yeah ♪
♪ When I get home ♪
♪ Woo hoo hoo ♪
♪ Yeah, baby, when I get home ♪
♪ I need some respect ♪
♪ R-E-S-P-E-C-T ♪
♪ Find out what it means to me ♪
♪ Take care, TCB ♪
♪ Yeah, baby, when I get home ♪
♪ Ooo ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Welfare moms in New Haven
were having their benefits cut,
and a bunch of us Yalees
went and protested
with the welfare moms sitting in at the,
one of these welfare offices.
And the police came and said,
"Those of you who don't wanna
be arrested, please leave.
"Those of you who do, stay."
And the welfare moms all stayed.
All but two of us Yalees left.
I and another woman stayed.
We were arrested.
I was only 17 at the time
so the dean of my college
had to be my guardian,
and not withstanding
my liberal parents, they were not happy
to hear when I called from jail.
Three weeks in, I did make the
cover of the Yale Daily News.
(audience laughing)
- It was a galvanizing time
about what side were you on.
You know, what did you think about what
was going on, not only in New Haven
but in the broader
United States community.
And so, yes, it was a big,
big deal about student unrest.
- The president suspended
academic expectations
or something like that so
that students could leave.
Some students left.
I stayed, but some
demonstrators were talking
about shutting down Yale.
And the university decided
to allow demonstrators
to camp in the colleges, not in the rooms,
but in the courtyards and feed them.
- We were serving food in the courtyards
to the people who were coming in,
but it was, you know,
it was fairly basic fare
that you could cook in huge quantities.
And anybody who wanted to could come in.
- Calhoun decided that it,
the thing it could do best
would be to have a hot
line so that we would,
dispel the fake news, right, and be
the source of true news, of real news.
So, I did my dishing up of
the food to whoever showed up
and manned the hot line.
- So, things start
heating up on the campus,
and my mom in New York kept saying,
"Well, why don't you just come home?
"I mean, they're suspending exams.
"They're, you know, you can
write your papers at home.
"There are no classes.
"Why don't you please come home?"
And I really felt like I
didn't want to abandon Yale so.
They did at Trumbull clean out,
asked us to leave if we could
the women's entryway.
So, again, it's about the women
because they really felt they didn't know
if they could sustain security.
- Suddenly, Yale is a place where there
were teach-ins on the weekend
about the atrocities in Vietnam.
SDS was starting up.
Black Panthers were
having rallies downtown.
My own guidance counselor, because I had
gone to some of these things,
said to me in his office,
"You people should all
be lined up and shot."
- You know, there were wiretaps
going on amongst students
and administrators and professors.
Oh, yeah, there were people who were,
who got compensated after the fact
for having been illegally wiretapped.
Students and faculty
and administrators.
- We had a guy who said he was a reporter
following us around all the time
because he wanted the inside story.
I decided with, you know, not at the time,
but this guy must have been, you know,
CIA or something or FBI.
- I was hanging out also with the,
one of the sub-groups I
met at that initial event,
ended up hanging out with
William Sloane Coffin Jr.
and Phil Zader, his assistant chaplain.
And we were all hanging out together,
and it turned out later
that I got named in a class
action suit and got $1000
'cause my phone was tapped by the CIA
and the city of New Haven.
- There were a lot of desperate groups,
you know, each of whom
was jockeying for power
and control over the movement
in a sense and the event.
And I don't think everything
was perfectly peaceful.
I, there was tear gas.
- I remember running away
from the New Haven police
and running into Vanderbilt.
And I peeked out the window, and I know
I saw a cop throw a tear gas canister
over the fence at Vanderbilt.
And then, my memory is that, you know,
one of my roommates was in there.
So, she was like, "What's goin' on here?"
So, I said, "Well, we'll
get the washcloths,
the wet washcloths, over
your nose and get down."
- And it was scary to a
little 17, 18-year-old kid,
I mean, a sheltered kid from Chevy Chase.
It was very scary.
- It was such a stressful time,
not because of the demonstrators
but because of the politics.
President Nixon started bombing Cambodia
just a couple days before
the May Day demonstration.
A few days after that were
the Kent State shootings,
and at least one student was killed.
- It was the first year of co-education,
the first year of Bobby
Seale going on murder trial,
then the Kent State killings.
It was really enough to make any
middle-class girl's head
spin around 10 or 12 times.
- So, this is Elga
Wasserman's exact words.
"The media threat, the media treated
"the advent of women as
a weird and novel event,
"as if creatures from
Mars had invaded Yale.
"In the beginning, few women felt
"as if they were truly belonged
"in this bastion of future male leaders.
"Oddly enough, from my perspective,
"May Day 1970 became the best thing
"that happened to Yale co-education.
"The external threat of May
Day unified the student body.
"Everyone pitched in together.
"Suddenly, gender was irrelevant,
"and undergraduate women had become
"an integral part of Yale College."
From Elga Wasserman.
- You know, I think that
for many in my generation
who were, who lived here then,
our, our moral compass was formed
by being students here, experiencing that,
and having that leadership
of those folks at that time.
(audience applauding)
At that moment, the spring of 1970,
we really did the earth
move under our feet.
To sing the Carole King song by that name
for us is Whim 'N Rhythm.
In 1981 Yale's a cappella scene
featured a number of single sex groups,
but that year seven Senior women felt
that a key part of the Yale musical scene
was missing a Senior
group that would rival
the decades old tradition
of the Whiffenpoofs.
Nearly 40 years later, the
singers of Whim 'N Rhythm
represent the best and most experienced
women singers in the Senior class.
Here they are singing
"I Feel the Earth Move."
(audience applauding)
♪ Do do do do do do ♪
♪ Ooo ooo ooo ooo ooo ooo ooo ♪
♪ Ooo ooo ooo ooo ♪
♪ I feel the earth move under my feet ♪
♪ I feel the sky tumbling down ♪
♪ Oh, I feel it tumble ♪
♪ I feel my heart start to tremblin' ♪
♪ Whenever you're around ♪
♪ Oh, darlin' ♪
♪ When I see your face ♪
♪ Mellow as the month of May ♪
♪ Oh, darlin', I can't stand it ♪
♪ When you look at me that way ♪
♪ I feel the earth move under my feet ♪
♪ I feel the sky tumblin' down ♪
♪ Oh, I feel it tumble ♪
♪ I feel my heart start a tremblin' ♪
♪ Whenever you're around ♪
♪ And when you are near me ♪
♪ I feel the earth move under my feet ♪
♪ Oh, I can't stand it ♪
♪ I'll come a runnin' ♪
♪ Winter, spring, and summer ♪
♪ Fall, I'm comin' ♪
♪ I said I feel it move ♪
♪ I feel it tumblin' down ♪
♪ I feel it runnin' through my veins ♪
♪ And it all comes tumblin' down ♪
♪ Oh, I feel it ♪
♪ Oh, darlin' ♪
♪ When you're near me ♪
♪ And you tenderly call my name ♪
♪ I know that my emotions ♪
♪ Are something I just can't tame ♪
♪ Can't tame my love or rapture, baby ♪
♪ I feel the earth move under my feet ♪
♪ I feel the sky tumblin'
down, a tumblin' down ♪
♪ I feel the earth move under my feet ♪
♪ I feel the sky tumblin'
down, a tumblin' down ♪
♪ And I just lose control ♪
♪ Down to my very soul ♪
♪ I get so hot and cold ♪
♪ All over ♪
♪ All over, all over, all over, all over ♪
♪ All over, all over, all over ♪
- [Woman] Two, three.
♪ I feel the earth move under my feet ♪
♪ I feel the sky tumbling
down, a tumbling down ♪
♪ I feel the earth move under my feet ♪
♪ I feel the sky tumblin'
down, a tumblin' down ♪
♪ A tumbling down, a tumbling down ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Thank you, beautiful, thank you.
Thank you, Whim 'N Rhythm.
That was really a beautiful performance.
One of the requests from
several members of the committee
was the next song from
the musical "Wicked."
Cami and her friend Noelle
Mercer, Class of '21,
vocalist and playwright, who has starred
in several Yale productions, will sing
this moving song called "For Good."
(audience applauding)
(gentle piano music)
♪ I've heard it said ♪
♪ That people come into
our lives for a reason ♪
♪ Bringing something we must learn ♪
♪ And we are led ♪
♪ To those who help us most to grow ♪
♪ If we let them ♪
♪ And we help them in return ♪
♪ Well, I don't know if
I believe that's true ♪
♪ But I know I'm who I am today ♪
♪ Because I knew you ♪
♪ Like a comet pulled from orbit ♪
♪ As it passes the sun ♪
♪ Like a stream that meets a boulder ♪
♪ Halfway through the wood ♪
♪ Who can say if I've been
changed for the better ♪
♪ But because I knew you ♪
♪ I have been changed for good ♪
♪ It well may be ♪
♪ That we will never meet again ♪
♪ In this lifetime ♪
♪ So let me say before we part ♪
♪ So much of me ♪
♪ Is made of what I learned from you ♪
♪ You'll be with me ♪
♪ Like a handprint on my heart ♪
♪ And now whatever way our stories end ♪
♪ I know you have re-written mine ♪
♪ By being my friend ♪
♪ Like a ship blown from its mooring ♪
♪ By a wind off the sea ♪
♪ Like a seed dropped by a skybird ♪
♪ In a distant wood ♪
♪ Who can say if I've been
changed for the better ♪
♪ But because I knew you ♪
♪ Because I knew you ♪
♪ I have been changed for good ♪
♪ And just to clear the air ♪
♪ I ask forgiveness ♪
♪ For the things I've
done you blame me for ♪
♪ But then I guess we know
there's blame to share ♪
♪ And none of it seems to matter anymore ♪
♪ Like a comet pulled from orbit ♪
♪ Like a ship blown from its mooring ♪
♪ As it passes a sun ♪
♪ By a wind off the sea ♪
♪ Like a stream that meets a boulder ♪
♪ Like a seed dropped
by a bird in the wood ♪
♪ Halfway through the wood ♪
♪ Who can say ♪
♪ If I've been changed for the better ♪
♪ I do believe I have been
changed for the better ♪
♪ And because I knew you ♪
♪ Because I knew you ♪
♪ I have been changed ♪
♪ For good ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Alright, alright.
Okay, alright.
Alright.
(audience laughing)
Yes, exactly.
We need to, we're resilient.
We respond to changes of circumstance.
Okay, Shades of Yale is
certainly among the most
recognized and most
popular groups of Yale.
Their name celebrates
the group's diversity
and the depth and complexity
of the black experience.
At a moment like this,
when we are honoring
the trailblazing women of the
classes of 1971, '72, and '73,
and all they did to overcome,
how could we not have Shades
sing their signature song?
It will be followed by a special thank you
video tribute from women
who are now at Yale.
So, women of Yale Collage who
were the first on this campus,
please help us welcome Shades.
(audience cheering and applauding)
♪ We shall overcome ♪
♪ Some day ♪
♪ Oh, deep ♪
♪ In my heart ♪
♪ I do believe ♪
♪ That we shall overcome ♪
♪ Some day ♪
♪ Sisters and brothers ♪
♪ We shall overcome ♪
♪ Some day ♪
♪ Day day some day ♪
♪ Oh, deep in my heart ♪
♪ Deep in my heart ♪
♪ I do believe ♪
♪ We shall overcome ♪
♪ Some day ♪
♪ Shall overcome ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
- We are welcoming the
Class of 2023 right now,
and it's so wonderful
to have an opportunity
to take a break and think
about the women of '69 to '73,
the people who actually led
the charge to come to Yale
to make it a place for
all of us to come to.
Thank you so much for everything you did
when you were here as a student,
for the many things you
do as alumni of Yale.
And I just wanna salute your
courage, your curiosity,
and thank you for taking that
first step for all of us.
- I wanna say thank you to the
first female students at Yale
for making it possible when
I was a student in the '90s
to feel like it was completely normal
for me to be on campus.
I now have the privilege of being the
Dean of Jonathan Edwards College,
and I see my female students occupying
leadership roles across campus.
It wouldn't be possible
without you so thank you.
- I have looked up to so
many of you for so long.
You include my heroines.
I feel as if I have personally stood
on the shoulders of so many of you.
I so hope this weekend has been memorable
and a little provocative.
My prayer is that something
during your time back
has seized your heart and will engage you
to come back often to
Yale in the coming years.
Bravo and thank you.
- The courage of one generation
makes possible the
accomplishments of the next.
We're grateful to inhabit the world
whose doors you opened.
Thank you.
- Kudos to the bold women of
Yale's first co-ed classes.
You challenged Yale to learn from you.
You made Yale better for the future.
And you inspired by your leadership
those who came after
you, including myself.
I was Yale's first women General Counsel
and served for 30 years.
Thank you for all you've done
for Yale and for the world.
- At the school of architecture,
Minerva presides over our design studios.
How wonderful is it that the
goddess of wisdom is our inspiration.
In that spirit, I'd like to thank
the women who came to Yale in the classes
of 1969 through 1973 for all
they brought to the university.
Bravo to you, goddesses
of wisdom, and thank you.
(audience laughing)
- That is what every woman
in the Yale Law School
building feels about the
generations that came before us.
I'm the first female
dean of Yale Law School.
This incoming class is 54% women.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Thank you for blazing the trails
and smoothing the path and
making all of this possible.
We are in your debt.
- I'm Daisy Mazzio-Manson, a
Senior here at Yale University.
In 1999 my mom made a film
called "A Hero for Daisy,"
which is a documentary
focusing on Chris Ernst
whose a Title IX pioneer and Olympian,
who led the 1976 Yale women's crew team
to protest the lack of facilities
available for female athletes.
Today, I'm a rower on the
Yale women's crew team,
where we have exceptional facilities
and an elite coaching staff who work
to provide us with all the
resources we need to excel.
I'm so thankful for the
women who came before me
and fought so hard for the
opportunities that we have today.
- Hi, Joliana Yee, and I just want
to extend the deepest
of gratitude and thanks
to the first women at Yale for,
because of your perseverance,
I'm allowed to stand here before you
as the Director of the Asian
American Cultural Center.
And especially a big shout
out to the women of color
because I know it wasn't easy.
Congratulations and thank you.
- I am so grateful for the women
at Yale who came before us.
It takes bravery, courage,
their love for Yale
to do what you've done,
and I'm a product of that.
And so, I'm so grateful and thankful
for the women at Yale
to bring in inclusivity,
leadership, bravery, and love.
Thank you, thank you so much.
- I simply can't imagine either my classes
or the colleges without all
the wonderful young women
I've come to know there.
Thanks so much to the women
of the classes of '69 to '73
for taking the big leap
and making it all possible.
- I want to take this opportunity
to thank the women who
arrived on the Yale campus
in the fall of 1969 to
transform this university.
For had you not made the change
of making Yale a place
that welcomed women,
Yale could not have become the
great university that it would become
in the last quarter of the 20th century.
Thank you.
- As someone following only
a few years behind you,
and as a woman in the
male-dominated field of physics,
I know exactly how important
you are as path breakers.
You led the most important
change in Yale's history.
So, thank you so much.
- What a long way Yale has come
since I arrived here in 1972 as a
newly mentored assistant professor.
It's good, and it's right that we
should celebrate, and I do.
But you know, there's still a ways to go.
(audience laughing)
- I follow in the
footsteps that you paved.
Thanks to you, the first
class of Yale women,
for your resiliency, strength, and poise.
Thanks to you, I too am Yale.
- To our pioneers, our first classes
of women at Yale College, we salute you.
We honor you.
Countless women and people
of all genders at Yale
and beyond are indebted to you
for blazing these paths
with such brilliance,
courage, grace, and tenacity.
Thank you, and happy anniversary.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you to everyone who contributed
to that wonderful, wonderful video,
which was really inspiring
and moving and gratifying
to feel that all of this has developed
from our initial steps here
back in 1969, '70 through '73.
The following song, sung by Cami,
is the one requested by the committee
to be the finale of the day.
It's a second song by Carole King,
but that's not the
reason it was requested.
The words represent to the
women who've requested it
the bond that all of us share
and the way we feel about one another.
The song will be immediately followed
by a brief closing
tribute by Kinsale Houston
after which Kinsale
will ask us all to rise
and sing "Bright College Years"
led by the Yale Precision Marching Band.
(audience laughing)
After we finish the alma mater,
please don't sit back down.
We are all going to gather our things
and follow the band,
marching to Phelps Gate,
where the commemorative
stone will be dedicated.
(audience laughing and chatting)
(audience applauding)
- One, two, three, four.
(mellow piano music)
♪ Mmm ♪
♪ When you're down and troubled ♪
♪ And you need a helping hand ♪
♪ And nothing, nothin' is going right ♪
♪ Mmm ♪
♪ Close your eyes and think of me ♪
♪ And soon I will be there ♪
♪ To brighten up even your darkest night ♪
♪ You just call out my name ♪
♪ And you know wherever I am ♪
♪ I'll come running ♪
♪ To see you again ♪
♪ Winter, spring, summer, or fall ♪
♪ All you've got to do is call ♪
♪ And I'll be there, yes, I will ♪
♪ You've got a friend ♪
♪ Ooo, you've got a friend ♪
♪ If the sky above you ♪
♪ Is dark and full of clouds ♪
♪ And that, that old north
wind begins to blow ♪
♪ Keep your head together ♪
♪ Soon I'll be knockin' at your door ♪
♪ Just call my name ♪
♪ You just call out my name ♪
♪ And you know wherever I am ♪
♪ I'll come running ♪
♪ To see you again ♪
♪ Winter, spring, summer, or fall ♪
♪ All you've got to do is call ♪
♪ And I'll be there ♪
♪ Yes, I will ♪
♪ Ain't it good to know ♪
♪ That you've got a friend ♪
♪ People can be so cold ♪
♪ They'll hurt you, desert you ♪
♪ They'll steal your
soul if you let them ♪
♪ So, don't you let them, no ♪
♪ You just call out my name ♪
♪ And you know wherever I am ♪
♪ I'll come running ♪
♪ Yes, I will ♪
♪ You've got a friend, oh oh ♪
♪ Winter, spring, summer, or fall ♪
♪ All you've got to do is call ♪
♪ And I'll be there ♪
♪ Yes, I will ♪
♪ You've got a friend ♪
♪ Ooo, you've got a friend ♪
♪ Ain't it good to know
that you've got one ♪
that you've got a friend ♪
♪ You ooo ooo ooo ooo ooo ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Will you not celebrate with us
the hands that have built our futures?
These women, straight
backed and bright eyed
in the black and white photographs,
their arms and books a shield,
their knowledge, their power.
These women are mothers,
their brightness echoing
off these stony walls.
You are the portraits on
the walls of Sterling,
gazing proudly with your
telescopes and chemistry.
When first I walked in with my father,
I was drawn to you, looked
up to your portraits
and smiled and said, "This
is why I'm here today."
These women who raised their
hands and raised their fists.
super women with raised
fists, you've raised us.
This is not a milestone
but a beginning again.
It is a reminder that we
women are not guests here.
We are the very backbone
of this institution.
All 2800 from 230,
you bring us together.
And we are the light and the lightning.
We are the cracking of
book spines and boldness.
We are bravery and strength.
This is woman to woman.
This is to 1969,
to trailblazers, to path breakers.
Woman to woman, we see you.
We are you.
We thank you.
(audience cheering and applauding)
And now, would everyone
please stay standing
for "Bright College Years."
(audience laughing)
Led by the Yale Precision Marching Band.
The words are on the back of your program,
and you should all have the white
handkerchief to wave at the end.
And we'll get started once
they're all in the room.
(audience chattering)
(marching band music)
♪ Bright college years
with pleasure rife ♪
♪ The shortest, gladdest years of life ♪
♪ How swiftly are ye gliding by ♪
♪ O why does time so quickly fly ♪
♪ The seasons come, the seasons go ♪
♪ The earth is green or white with snow ♪
♪ But time and change ♪
♪ Shall not avail ♪
♪ To break the friendships ♪
♪ Formed at Yale ♪
♪ In after years should trouble rise ♪
♪ To cloud the blue of sunny skies ♪
♪ How bright will seem
through memory's haze ♪
♪ Those happy golden bygone days ♪
♪ O let us strive that ever we ♪
♪ May let these words our watch cry be ♪
♪ Where e'er upon ♪
♪ Life's sea we sail ♪
♪ For God, for country, ♪
♪ And for Yale ♪
(audience cheering)